it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes Oh what in the world welcome to
movie fights hashtag movie fights live
we are doing it it is coming at ya we
are going to fight about movies got the
questions all lined up with some awesome
fighters first let me give a shout out
to Allen nation hoot hoot
hashtag owl nation Percival is in the
house like I said we've got some awesome
fighters let's meet our combatants first
up oh you know I'm from the nur deficit
podcast he is one of these oh he's one
of the biggest dragon ball z heads I've
ever met oh hell yeah yeah welcome back
to the party our friend if even wanna
wait hey how's it going yeah Dragon Ball
Z has we call each other the ball boys
boys we do this chair keeps sinking so
if you keep seeing me jump up throughout
this that's what's going on like I'm
getting lowered now but you know it's
all good you know what for once in my
life I feel a little bit more stout you
know so a GQ model oh yeah yeah GQ
Italia been telling y'all oh yeah you
can see it you can see him at the cons
you can see them on the runways if he's
not away glad to have you back buddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
oMG we're already off the rails a second
he's become a formidable fighter he's a
fan favorite you know from all over the
internets and right here
Cameron Rice Cameron welcome back to the
party hello thank you for having me
apparently I might owe you an apology
how just made a comment about like me
being hold of this but I was hosting but
you know what I'm just said I wasn't
here to say I resemble that remark but
Cameron and last but not least you know
from DC Daily Nerdist Collider its mark
iam Accardi the party McCarty thank you
especially what I found out I was going
up against these two I just like this is
gonna be this is gonna be so serious
serious action we're about to get it
some serious nerds would also like to
goof around so I'm excited for this one
and deciding the festivities is going to
be a combination of myself and the dance
on the damn cam dan Merle Danielle
Radford Dan Merle what's going on my
friend you know I was just reading about
how critical role got six million
dollars on their Kickstarter I'm
starting one for $60 to get an effing
chair that doesn't sink its in for years
that's stupid chair six six dollars six
dollars for a bolt to put in the chair
so it doesn't I know and it's like
sometimes it's like embarrassing like a
friend if he or like we're interviewing
the damn Russo brothers
there's going on there's hammers and
saws we can how we need help yeah true a
true story dan thank you for expressing
our pain about this chair and we have
our friend our social media chair the
voice of the people Danielle Radford
hello
so yeah the way this works is anytime
there's a tie or just an undecided vote
we will go to the poll on YouTube lots
of great polls the poll on YouTube is
the only one that counts and now you
those will go up once everyone's given
their initial arguments because we want
to make sure it's about the arguments
and not about which answer you like more
before you hear them if you have any
questions about the poll or how it works
click in the description or ask someone
in the chat I'm sure someone can help
you out also I will be looking for
responses on movie fights live hashtag
movie fights live on Twitter so if you
post something in there and I like it I
might shut you out on the show oh heck
yes and you know we're looking for you
like your answers are the questions and
like stupid memes just dank dumb memes
also if you were wondering if it really
wasn't GQ Italian you can find that
online
hell yeah look at me and then the
conversation he had with his friend
group about it man but I came out on top
just a quick refresher as to how our
game works the first person to score
four points will walk out of here the
winner there are three regular rounds
than the top two performers from those
first three rounds we'll move on to the
speed around where it's anybody's ball
game so I'm gonna be up by three
and the person who's down can make a
furious comeback in the speed round you
want to have some movie fights fun
that's a guest package against the
microphone question number one so
captain Marvel's captain marvel singular
hits theaters this weekend I'm gonna see
it tomorrow night if it's going to be
revealed that one member of the MCU cast
has been a Skrull all along who should
it be who should be the scroll in our
midst and we're gonna start with player
number one if he um Hawkeye because I
feel like you know he's been around he's
been present and the fans are actually a
little bit attached to him in a way that
what that will kind of bamboozle people
and it all kind of makes sense in ways
because you know him being gone during
all the events that went down and him
popping back up and him coming and going
it's like oh yeah no I can see you're up
to no good you're keeping an eye on
people and that's when when you were
gone you were reporting to the scrolls
right on yeah where was he all that time
maybe reporting to the scrolls Thank You
iffy Cameron who you got I decided to go
with an option that would shake the
foundation of the emcee only fans shook
I'm going with Black Widow Scarlett
Johansson's Black Widow along with a B I
think this also explains quite a lot of
things especially her consistently
changing looks from Phil in the film why
she's always looking different and why
was she so willing to give up shield
information at the end of Winter Soldier
because she's not actually black
no she's a scroll and it also give us
Marvel a backdoor to be like we couldn't
make her own movie because it hasn't
been her that's an interesting take at
the end there Cameron Thank You Marcia I
went with agent Phil Coulson because it
makes a lot of sense for him to infinity
because all the whole thing about
Scrolls is infiltration so you want
someone that will rise to the ranks and
to a power into a powerful position so
Phil Coulson is the best possible person
for that because not only do you have
somebody that's in with the Avengers and
is trusted by them but they're also in
with shield I mean this is a perfect fit
this is like a DNA match just like a
scroll Wow
all right fight it out you guys mmm all
right so for Black Widow
Cameron she's a human being she's a
woman we change our look constantly so
that's not something that would be a
scroll like behavior and I'm I'm
offended that you would say that but for
her like couldn't make a movie about her
that doesn't make any sense it's like
I'm talking about marble marble is now
has the reason to be like we didn't do
it for ten years because we have this
planche she got the man came looking for
a marble this was bar
would feel too easy and cheap with a
scroll reveal it has to be like I
remember opening Secret Invasion and be
like yo and that's what you want to
convey and that's why I think someone
like Hawkeye because I feel like Black
Widow she been there just a little bit
too much like someone like Hawkeye who
has a fake family you know this man is
over there
players on the board Iron Man 3
who are you know Counting watch the
watch the over-talking guys keep it
coming keep going he's exactly what
Coulson is exactly what a scroll should
be
infiltrating into the system collecting
the information and turning the
narrative that is what scroll and he has
not only done that in the MCU but he is
managed to do that in the MC secret
event invasion and what secret invasion
was all about as a crossover event is
[ __ ] the minds of all the fans
everyone has been activity we never
trusted you family thanks to its like it
makes more sense for Coulson and Black
Widow to be a scroll that does for our
it does make sense for blacks even more
sense for Coulson because that would be
a good choice I'm describing why it
would be a good movie because everyone
has doubted Hawkeye so when you cease to
and we get to show how badass Hawkeye
actually is when he comes back it's like
y'all doubted me y'all thought I was
weak check out the scroll action plan on
that out oh you see
all of it big scroll chin in that purple
actually you like damn is that panels
nah man it's a damn scroll and your
whole thing with black widow giving up
the information that proves that she's
not a good scroll scroll so don't give
that up because it does not help them if
they don't makes people distrust the
eagle tomorrow door storytelling we play
with things and we make things that
don't make sense come together in a way
to make something beautiful and exciting
to watch a good ending isn't anything
that makes you go of course black widow
being a scroll makes everyone go
of course you keep saying she changing
every after every breakup a woman change
their hair color guess what if you go
see Captain Marvel what Scrolls are in
that movie and what the scrolls are in
the comic you know that's the nuance of
the square
my Hawkeye Wow okay you know what um if
he lets shift gears go ahead and make
this your final thought okay okay the
reason I say why Hawkeye is because you
want you want to kind of blindside your
audience we don't trust Black Widow and
that's the fun with her because you're
not supposed to trust a spy character
but if she's a scroll that it's like
yeah duh that's why we never trusted it
you're gonna lead into the audience's
intuitions Coulson we already talked
well we all agree he's off the board man
what you're gonna tie in agents of
shield the TV show yeah now we can't do
that Hawkeye the fans want more Hawkeye
and the fans want Hawkeye to be
respected because Hawkeye is us the
little guy without powers cheering on
the rest of the Avengers and then we get
to see him be badass we get to feel
badass
Hawkeye for president 2020 whoa thank
you for that sir Cameron what do you got
final thoughts Coulson off the board you
can't cry in six seasons of a television
show hot guy has not been present for
like four years now Willis no more three
four years ago guy has not been present
I feel like especially after this movie
we got to think about what's the next
thing that happens after infinity what
happens after you have killed half not
just of the Avengers half the universe
what's the next thing how do you keep
building I think you got to shake that
foundation you got to shake the bedrock
you do that by going this character who
has been in every movie pretty much
actually a scroll
that's why Tony Stark couldn't trust her
that's why Steve Rogers couldn't trust
her that's why everyone can trust her I
hear what you're saying it's like oh
well you're playing to the audience
expectation that's not necessarily a bad
thing sometimes playing with the
audience's expectation what they think
is gonna happen that's how you get some
great motion pictures
talkies were they talking Thank You
Cameron Markie McCarty your final
thoughts okay so the whole point of a
scroll is to be able to be in a position
of power to be able to turn the
narrative to be able to help the scroll
nation and help the infiltration of
earth that is the whole point of the
whole the scroll thing so with Hawkeye
it doesn't make sense because he's not
really in a position of power and this
whole attached to him thing people
people actually feel a little bit
betrayed of Hawkeye and it to be a
scroll but not portrayed in the good way
betrayed in the oh really really that
one okay I guess kind of a way and with
Black Widow camp you scroll she's just
way too antagonistic not not be a
character that would keep on putting
itself into the limelight like Black
Widow does too and she puts herself into
all of these different it's it's it's
bit too on-the-nose and it's not scroll
like behavior well with Coulson you have
Coulson be the scroll you've had this
person that has been popping up in these
little ways you know and like Thor and
everything in like a and the the
Avengers like the original one and you
had like oh no he said oh no they Nick
Fury brought him back it took an act of
God that kind of thing that they said so
you have Coulson via scroll not only do
you affect the MCU
but you affect the MCU TV by doing that
when he came back in season five and
they're like oh how are you doing how
are you and he's like I don't remember a
lot of things why because they had to
take back out the scroll stuff to even
put more Phil Coulson stuff back in and
then going into season six it makes
sense to have him continue as a scroll
because you saw it an in-game time all
right Wow three different characters
points of view arguments good stuff Dan
rural what do we got in the fact zone
well when it comes to one of the Rings
and whatever Pete see what's been yelled
at me in a thousand comments is that the
Eagles are a proud race
that's what I yelled told every time I
asked why the Eagles don't fly the
hobbits come on do my baby proud race
they're not carrying his water one favor
has been off the board for about well we
should say he was last seen in civil war
which was about two years since from
infinity war so not on scream directly
at about two years of marble or than see
you time that's what we're looking at no
there's some question about how long he
been gone
couple years at least on screen so a
long time then breaks out on that
intelligence thank you sir
all right yeah I really was feeling all
three of these arguments at different
times
Cameron what you were but some of the
stuff you were backing up your uh your
Black Widow argument with like as far as
her changing her look how many different
suits is he has something some movies
bearded some movies his beardless you
know so I don't know like that and that
was such a huge part of your like and I
was brought up so many times oh yeah so
it that started to eat away at the Black
Widow Lady Gaga also a scroll
what about Ali from star is born' a
scroll as well so it came down to mark
iya and iffy for me and yeah I mark yeah
you started to really come on at the end
with incorporating some of the stuff
from agents of shield but overall I feel
like if he's just if he's timeline and
if he's just thoughts about the
whereabouts of Hawkeye with his
potentially fake family and that was
really I don't know that really
intrigued me and it just got me on the
Hawkeye train so I'm going if he Dan
Merle I would have to agree that while
Scrolls are known for being
shapeshifters that seem to be all I was
getting from Cameron's argument and I
felt like if he and Mark you both had a
much a little bit more of a fleshed-out
reasoning behind why they picked certain
things to be Scrolls and I thought that
I liked both angles I liked the Coulson
memory angle I also liked the Hawkeye
angle and ultimately I think if I was in
my head if I was trying to decide which
one would I do I think would be like the
best scenario the one that I would
believe the most I could honestly
believe that Hawkeye had a secret was a
secret scroll with a secret scroll
family that's why we've never seen them
before age of Ultron and that's where
they were this whole time so you have to
go Hawkeye secret scroll family and if
they BAM if he gets the point that means
Linda Cardellini is also a scroll
Danielle what that's true yeah Danielle
what did the poll say about this home
well with 49 percent Hawkeye and his
secret family
3% Agent Coulson 17% black widow some
really good things on the hashtag I
really like this one from college movie
man who said oh my god Sharon Carter is
a scroll convenient no one knew she was
Peggy's niece and Peggy was suffering
from dementia and could neither confirm
nor deny the perfect alibi for me
College movie guys good arguments all
around no mug lumps in the bunch but if
he takes the point Cameron and Marky
looking to get on the board let's go to
question number two Benji I hope you
heard my shout out okay here it is
Captain Marvel it's set in the 1990s
what other franchise should do a
throwback 90s prequel all right hey the
90s are cool again you guys what other
franchise should do a throwback 90s
prequel question to start player to
Cameron so with this one I actually
tried to think about a movie where being
in the 90s is actually going to be an
intrinsic part of the story and not just
a way for simple throwaway gags like
someone mentioning Jim Carrey being
popular or some TV shows and things like
that and that's how you know it's in the
90s I tried to think of a movie or
franchise that it could actually help
this story I picked happy deathday
because if no one's seen happy deathday
1 & 2 it's a bat it's the Groundhog's
Day idea with a serial killer but
there's also this continuous storyline
with the character tree her mother that
her mother had passed away it plays a
big part in the second film about tree
having to go to an alternate timeline in
finding her mother still alive and that
becomes a big part of the second film to
me I think the third film to continue
that to continue to make this like a
full trilogy and to continue pushing
because again happy deathday to was sort
of playing listen back to the Future
stuff my mindset is go full Back to the
Future throw tree back into the 90s and
she meets her mother young in her normal
timeline and so again rather than
offering the question of you can stay in
a different universe with your mom still
alive
it's here's a timeline with your mother
still alive at your age you're still
playing with some of the slasher killer
babyface stuff you're continuing on with
the time
universe stuff the happy deathday has
been doing and continuing on from 1 to 2
you're making like a totally new
different kind of movie rather than a
rehash of the first one interesting
stuff Thank You Cameron mark eeeh ok I
went with well for what I was looking
for with this is that I love it when
prequels go seamlessly into like the
first movie and actually stimulate your
ability to want to watch the rest of
that franchise again so I went with 28
days later and the title of the film
will be 28 hours later obviously because
the third film is called was it a 28
weeks 20 weeks later thank you so with
with this the set of would be that it
would be in one of the suburbs of
Cambridge since the beginning of 28 days
later starts in the University of
Cambridge specifically where in there
the primate the primate division and you
have 90s 90s British suburbia and so
you're you're invested into that and
you're like oh so it's like us as
Americans we see parts of our America
you know like over there because you
know 90s was pretty pretty big
everywhere American 90s so we see that
and then actually the journey would be
the researcher that you see at the
beginning at 28 days later you have him
as the older brother giving a gift of a
monkey to his younger brother and you're
like oh that's cute oh no no it's the
monkey thing and then you cut to that 28
hours later and you have the rampant
running through the streets and you're
thinking oh why would he do like to give
this like reach monkey - it's like no no
it turns out it doesn't like that
there's a twist and I'll get to that in
my final argument
ladies having a monkey that's kind of
yeah there's someone give me a monkey as
a gift what do you got
Hey so yeah this was such a fun question
everyone's like answers are super fun
and well thought out and it really does
kind of fall into like your taste for
stuff and genuinely like I think what
really is hidden for a captain a Captain
Marvel and like other movies that take
place in like set time periods is really
kind of just given into the world and I
think cam was right you don't want to go
for the cheap jokes you want to kind of
live in it you want to you want to
explore it but also I think you know as
a movie it's good to kind of like play
with it
artistically and kind of like dip into
maybe a movie that would exist in that
time which is why I want among for many
reasons to reboot the x-men franchise
and do a prequel in the 90s mostly
because the x-men already is the
Breakfast Club so why not make a full
x-men origin story that is the Breakfast
Club and you you already have all the
different archetypes you know Wolverine
the bad boy you got Cyclops the teachers
pat you got trying to braid the star
student rogue the goth chick so why not
like fully lean into it and really
explore these characters in a new way
recast them and launch it off and
obviously I would I would do the twist
in this would instead of being like you
know this mean dude teacher storm as the
teacher she's the leader of the moment
because she should have always been the
leader of x-men why are we even
bothering with Cyclops I know I lost
some of y'all a storm is the true leader
of the x-men so like you got straight up
punk teacher because my thing too is
like when you borrow from a franchise to
also kind of add a flare on it and so we
don't want to beat for beat breakfast
club so we have this like the hot
teacher which is gonna be storm and you
get to see these characters play out
learn to be each other and it kind of
fits right into x-men because it takes
place in a school like at at the end of
the day the x-men kind of is the
Breakfast Club when you go to its
origins and you look at Xavier Academy
for the gifted so why
not have these New Mutants who are all
in detention and learning about
themselves that power may be their
sexuality and and you know and and also
who is this old-ass Wolverine so I like
I like both these I guess my my question
is why does it have to be in the 90s
what's the what's the 90s of it because
I know x-men blew up for us in the 90s
Gimli and everything but x-men goes back
to the 60s and 70s like what is it about
this because I love The Breakfast Club
idea and I love all that stuff and
beyond like cheap jokes where it's like
what's a cell phone yes you know like
well the reason is the main reason I
want to reboot the sequel is so it can
learn right up into the MCU this is
going to lead into the MCU where do they
existed and this goes into my big theory
that when when we break reality with the
Infinity Gauntlet that we're gonna
reveal that mutants have always existed
and have been hidden but you know baby
beyond that like that's why you would
take place than 90 that actually has
strength to it and then kind of ride
that out I don't think it'd be like a no
cellphones joke it really would be
living in this world and you'd be beyond
self I'm like what what is like what was
racism in the 90s guess what we're gonna
memory mimic that and I think the best
example if anybody's watching pin 15 I
think they've done the best racism
episode on TV because it's it's not the
like okay when the 90s it was like we
don't know necessarily this thing is
making you feel shitty and it's just
jokes and so like so like to explore
that with like the mutant stuff and to
see like the ways that that would be
implemented that just is interesting to
me
it kind of that's kind of been the
beauty of x-men is like it was cool when
it first started and we had this heavy
fisted allegory for racism but let's now
use it for a stronger allegory that can
influence a younger generation yeah I
just have to say for like my first
inclination I I mean I I like this idea
but it's like my first inclination is
like god I'm so sick of x-men reboots
I'm so tired of them constantly doing
this constantly messing up the timeline
constantly doing that and it's and it's
just I I don't have any faith that it
can be done well in the way that you're
saying with it like with what they've
done with x-men what what I need from
x-men now now that you know that's going
back under the umbrella of Disney I need
for them to take a big old paws on that
like just take a big on pause take a big
ol step back because they have Dark
Phoenix and they have to keep taking
place already true it's like they've
already they've already touched on this
true feel the exact same way the exact
same I felt the exact same way about
Peter Parker and spider-man and then how
come he came out because and then that
was the proof in the pudding that then
homecoming came out they tested him with
Civil War first is a singular spider-man
movie that came out and proved that when
you do it right it doesn't quit and
that's kind of what you would do with
this is we don't do the origin story
over and over I love the 28 days later
series I love those two films I think
for me the only issue I have with going
back is that and trying to do 28 hours
is that I feel like what kind of made
the 28 days later series interesting was
a kind of what made the Walking Dead
interesting is you're continuing to see
what happens with the outbreaks goodness
is I think going back it's just like
okay this is Night of the Living Dead
but they run it's still just a suburban
town if anything we get to have a lot of
nuance when it comes because the whole
thing about zombie movies is about it is
social commentary what it is and then
having it set it specifically has to be
set in the 90s since the first one came
out in 2003 so for this it's like you
get to have that slice of life that
culture that is 90s Britain you
that suburban life in Britain we we get
to see a lot of American stuff but we
get to see that with their and what it
is it's like how did the world not know
about it that is part of the thing where
it's like you because so many things
happen that if it doesn't make it on
social media we don't hear about it so
what is this this event that happened
you know in you know the suburbs of
Cambria where a Cambridge where it's
like it didn't get out that they managed
to contain it like I want it I want to
see I want to see that happen because
you know what we haven't had that on a
mainstream scale and those guys can make
how are we gonna do about the
anachronisms with the next movies
because we don't really see that is the
thing there wouldn't be because they
contained it and it would be about
having this this vibrancy like run
rampant really stop they stopped her
from now okay for 28 days later to
happen you have to have the rage virus
you have to have and the researcher in
particular the beginning of that they're
like hey why did you infect this monkey
with this it's like and he and he's like
we didn't but you have to you have to
you have to understand or he's like we
have we have to infect to understand and
you know then we're getting into like
how did Logan get his jacket my problem
with a happy death day is now you're
putting the hat on hat what makes happy
deathday so amazing is that it's
Groundhog's Day yeah a horror so now
it's Groundhog Day and Back to the
Future but its horror
well now that was the second one yeah
which got really good like it's kind of
batshit insane everywhere
I saw it I saw it it goes everywhere
they even they they I mean they had they
had her I mean they had her skydive
naked out of something and flick off a
camera it went every Garry's Cameron I
want you to respond to this and then
roll that right into your final thoughts
I agree that its comedic it has comedic
elements it plays and tone it's not just
a straight horror movie and I think the
second one really works so because the
grounding of the relationship between
her and her mother and asking that
question about what will you do and
actually giving a character a hard
choice to make I think that's why
actually the second one really stands on
its own beyond just a repeat of the
first and I think pushing it further
into the third one because we see at the
end of the second one not to spy I think
it's the end the second one really
promises like hey this might become a
bigger thing there might be further
time-travel if you're going to do that I
think the idea of really wrapping it up
doing a full like a full trilogy here's
the full story of tree I think the idea
of putting it in the 90 she's meeting
her mother at a similar age and maybe
the same thing is happening to her mom
and it's tree who's outside the bubble
trying to figure that out it has to be
set in the 90s because that's the age
her mother would have been to be going
to college as opposed to the x-men thing
I love the idea but it feels like that
could be kind of anytime and the 28 days
later one again it feels like well
that's when it has to connect to 28 days
later but that came out in 2003 but this
isn't in 1999 it doesn't really feel
like I think mine might fit well I guess
we're gonna find out the twist is my
thing is I feel like it intrinsically
ties into the trilogy as a whole pushing
the story as opposed to repeating the
story thank you sir mark yeah uh yeah so
with 28 hours later with it it's just
going to it's going to complete this
trilogy and that's one of the things
that I feel like prequels need to do it
needs to have a same voice but different
story type of a deal and with like 28
hours later you're gonna get not only
that slice of life you're gonna follow
the story of this research for this
older brother and in this community and
then like this this rage virus that it
seems like it comes out of nowhere and
then it actually ends up that it's just
a distilled version that it's been it's
part of all of us but it's a distilled
version that's gone through this one
family and that the researchers little
brother is the one that acts
ends up carrying it and he's the one
that's that he ends up biting somebody
and then they become like you know one
of those rage monsters at the conclusion
of it the the older brother ends up
getting the monkey the monkey that he
gave to the younger brother the younger
brother ends up biting it and then
that's how he gets you know that
encapsulated he has to kill go around
and kill everybody in the community to
keep it like under wraps when the
government comes in they're like what is
this you know show them test and show
the monkey they're like well nobody can
ever know about this kind of a thing and
then you go into 28 days later where
he's a researcher in that primate lab
and you have the PETA people come in and
he's like no you mustn't you have to
kill them right then in this poor person
you see them like flashing back where
they had to kill their own little
brother to stop it but you know while
you're watching this movie that it's
doomed to happen again and it makes you
want to watch 20 days later in 28 weeks
later and that is what a prequel should
do sounds like fun movie marathon thank
you Mark all right all right so like I
said great points made like cam said
with his final statement you don't want
a movie that's going to be just a rehash
of rehash of rehash which by definition
a movie that's Groundhog Day does in
itself it's the definition of the movie
and like Marky says it needs to complete
a trilogy but when you have people
online asking for 28 months later it
won't complete the trilogy because we're
still waiting for 28 months later where
is 28 months later and there's already a
lot of anachronism just happening with
the connection of the two movies for me
we need a new x-men there's no way the
current x-men can just lead into this
this this current MCU we know that I
know that that's why we have to redo
spider-man Garfield wasn't that bad that
bad it's easy to see the new the new
spider-man and look at those ones be
like whoa what were we doing and that's
what I'm hoping to do with the x-men and
it does fit because we have to find
where in time we're gonna plug the x-men
so it lines up with the rest of the MCU
and what better way than to do a prequel
that takes place in the 90s that does
something fun because the recipe that
Marvel has figured out
that has made every Marvel movie good
that you know DC has had its troubles is
that they find a drop jean-louis and
they don't make a superhero movie so
that's why you would make The Breakfast
Club and it would come together and then
we'd smash cut to the future and then
we'd have Avengers vs. x-men after this
whole infinity war action time alright
wow that's a great round you guys I mean
I want to see all your movies so this is
a damn hard one dan what do you got over
there factually and thoughts on the
round please awesome the round off
actually I guess I'll just combine them
like there's mostly pitches and there's
a couple things yeah here and there but
I think I'm gonna go with Cameron
because I felt like he gave the best
pitch as to why this movie specifically
had to take place in the 90s and I know
that the the prequel to 28 days later
there's a time element but just in
hearing the pitch I wasn't exactly I
still wasn't clear on exactly why even
though the create days later came out
2003 why this one would be in the 90s I
was very fuzzy on the details and the
timelines and how exactly it would all
work together and what the time jump was
and everything else and I liked I liked
if he's idea about the x-men but you
know it for me it's more like why the
x-men needs to be rebooted and storm
being the leader like those are all
great ideas but I felt Cameron was the
one who's who's pitched the best movie
of as far as why it needs to be in that
era what is it gonna add to the current
series how it bears on the bigger
overall mythology in the story as a
prequel slash sequel so my pick would be
Cameron from this row right on thank you
Dan yeah I really like Cameron's I liked
I liked if he's to like it really spoke
to me although Breakfast Club you can't
bring a Breakfast Club and I love those
parallels that you set like if someone
hasn't mean to that stuff they should
Judd Nelson and Wolverine etc but the
eight that's an 80s reference ah and
and so add that like I don't know that
kind of stuck in my craw a little bit
even though I was just loving your
description of x-men so I don't know I
was kind of going around with that and
it came down to at the end with for
Cameron and Martina for me I feel like I
just didn't hear enough from camera and
I feel like you just literally didn't
like speak out enough about your idea
and I heard more from Mark eeeh that
kind of yeah I kind of want to see it
like a 28 origin story of the thing and
that's the one that like yeah I just
yeah I just couldn't stop thinking about
that gets my vote so it's one for
Cameron one from archaea let's go to
Danielle to hopefully break this tie
nope second we have x-men 32% we have
happy deathday and at 18% 28 days later
that was a perfectly time note thank you
so again I agree with everyone I want to
see all of these movies I want to see
all of these pitches yes you're gonna
wait to the tie I'm gonna break the tie
because for me the 90s of it all 80's
90's whatever it's just too young
none of that mattered I thought that he
had a really compelling pitch so I'm
gonna go with iffy on that one right on
iffy you take that point nicely done sir
and if he you vault into a 200 lead a
commanding 200 lead we're moving to
question number three when Cameron and
Mark Kia looking to get on the board
all right oh there's that fun one it's a
lot of work so I'm just gonna read this
[Music]
okay so on Twitter and you should follow
all these funny folks on Twitter by the
way on Twitter if he alleged that he
could fight a gorilla and win
oh yeah show me good choice I think it
was like there was a football player who
talked about fighting a wolf was Arian
Foster race the wolf IRL I lost but yes
feed on power yes so if he lets you can
fight a gorilla and win strength is
tough we want to know which I'm gonna
cut that on just the Laura because there
were things that I said yeah yeah I know
I can't grill is a strong I can't find a
gorilla heads up under the right
constraints if a gorilla had weights to
weaken itself and it only had its you
know gorilla type abilities to go
strength to strength this was not part
of the question
all right so we want another question
here
we want to know which non-powered
non-superhero quote unquote movie
character would you want would you want
to help you take on a gorilla and here's
some gorilla specs this is a lowland
gorilla from western Africa it's five
feet tall weighs about 300 pounds you're
fighting it in the gorilla enclosure at
the LA Zoo it has eaten today but only
once and it was several hours ago so
does that mean it's hangry I don't know
what that alright so you have you have
the specs you have where it's going to
take place
what non-powered movie character is do
you want on your side to help you fight
this beast uh mark eeeh start us off
yeah well the first thing that I thought
of when I was thinking of non-powered
movie characters I was like well I'm not
gonna go human because I'm not gonna put
a human versus a gorilla because that's
that freaking insane
that's that's just your why are you
trying to like lose this match
non-powered movie character I'm going
for the Dilophosaurus from Jurassic Park
and for those as with the rattling and
the big frill on everything the one that
um takes out dennis need jury once he he
falls he falls off that mountain over at
that point she brought it up
and the one who easily eats him he was
he's at least 300 plus pounds kind of a
thing and uh yeah the Dilophosaurus that
way night yeah yeah yeah well in in that
role it yes like he is so and obviously
over five feet and yes I have a source
took it like that alright
the Dilophosaurus from Jurassic Park
Marc Kia breaking out of the dinosaurs
if he you know okay so since I was
actually trying to you know come with
the sane person you're really fighting
against a Magic the Gathering character
and you are not ready for what I'm about
to bring down so imagine for gathering
players not a character guys I'm not
Gideon
I chose yes none other van and I got a
whole reason because like yeah I want
the you matter and taking on a gorilla
as I've known I think the only one at
the table who's researched this greatly
and not only does it take power not only
does it take speed it takes mental
capacity and grit which is why I chose
John McClane see because boom he's a
divorced dad he's a divorce he's a
divorced guy divorced dad once my wife
finds out I'm about to take on a gorilla
I'm gonna be a divorced dad that's two
divorced dad's coming together
you can't stop - divorced - yeah you
just can't stop the courts can you yes
[Music]
can that be my answer could the court
the two divorced dads have been waking
up in sweatpants for so long and have so
much pent-up aggression that's already
done leash that after two divorced dad's
and in this scenario since we set up a
whole last scenario it's our weekend to
take care of our kids sure and we're in
this grill and on both of our kids got
thrown in there so Jai Courtney and now
upon this one gorilla and we ate today
oh my goodness all right Cameron what do
you got all right I tried to come at
this also with logic and facts first of
all you don't pick the t-rex please I
picked Dutch from predator hmm not only
can he blast people away with a gun he's
got that big old gun that's not a
superpower that's just called machinery
anybody can have that America's got a
problem
secondly secondly let's say he loses the
guns as he did in predator he's in the
gorilla enclosure what does he do he
muds himself up Dutch is a thinker Dutch
is a guy who comes in with a plan he
knows how to lift logs build traps
he took out a pressure I looked up
predator stats predator had no problem
fooling Sonny up a tree predator
probably matches a gorilla for strength
and probably more vicious and Dutch took
out a predator John McClane can barely
take out the second boss in his movies
out pal shoot the old German get out
fight it out
you seem like you're really mad they
said non-powered movie Tara because
non-powered you're done sort of the
waffle source does not spit venom that
is something they movie character can't
view this is the del IVA source from the
movie so even though it's scientifically
she's disqualified by picking the
powered movie character because that
quick maybe John McClane in real life if
I stepped on all that glass I would be
down and out okay for this round as Deb
just said the movies are can and the
movies are what we're counting
please continue a conversation so cuz
there's a lotta soros was so lame none
of the movies even brought them back
even in the leave in the Jurassic world
the most like Pandora film were like
that guys laying it out here he only
killed Dennis Nedry a character that
even nice John Hammond had to make fat
jokes about that's the only character
Dilophosaurus Chuck you pick the weakest
of the bunch you got some
actually was so that means you either
have a smaller dinosaur that can spit
venom and can barely attack because it
cannot survive in the remain and we're
in the gorilla enclosure I couldn't do a
t-rex because the t-rex was too big
while the dinosaurs does fit in that and
as you can see in like Jurassic Park
when it is standing up to destroy Dennis
need jury it is almost near his height
and that is the movie character die low
that is that is going to look it up so
so you're you're saying Dutch we're
saying um we're trying to overpower
gorilla you you want to you're bringing
guns you said you said that you would
bring Dutch with guns shooting a gorilla
you can do that anyone can do that guns
are cheap and that's not that's not
without the guns he's got them traps but
he's kept on bringing up predator you
kept on bringing up him being a predator
why didn't you just choose predator
superpower why do you pick predator you
should be disqualified for that bad
choice
and it's like also another reason to
have the dialogue because of the
spitting venom venom their pee paralyzed
and they blind and what they don't do
unleash the attack until it's like yeah
okay we've got this kind of a thing so
they would go up to the gorilla you know
and what's her name Laci Lucy what's her
name a little bit hangry and for some
reason me you know we've decided to take
down this gorilla but we're not gonna
kill it because that's ridiculous like
what firepower and and we're not gonna
throw a you know like throw my divorce
dad angst at it so what we're gonna do
is that we're gonna have dialog go up
Fitness eyes paralyzed blind it's like
put my foot on it done it's gonna swing
those heavy ass Dilophosaurus
with like it's bite with what how it
went at Dennis need jury like you saw in
that either it's either going to run
away which is winning or is I want to
stand by that it's like I love John
McClane John McClane is great John
McClane though consistently has trouble
with 30-year old balding German men as
we've seen in two of the gun and Dennis
no no no that guy they beat each other
up if you remember the long haired
blonde guy that was a fistfight John
McClane does not do well
however the vengeance is on the boat
John McClane did not do well Tilly grab
the chains second one he almost got
taken down by Dennis Farina like Dennis
Franz Dennis Farina NYPD blue that actor
he almost got taken down until use the
blanks if the gorilla is not the main
villain John McClane is messed up if the
gorilla is the main villain gentleman
ain't got a chance buddy's gonna yell
foul he's gonna need Holly he needs
those assistance he needs Samuel Jackson
of Zeus to come in and save the day John
McClane can't do it only supposed to be
your assistant let's get some final
thoughts yeah I'm trying to think of
like the most effective and humane way
to take down this this you know this
Lucy to take down Lucy and it's like
yeah dialo paralyzes and blinds Lucy and
you know they keel over and you know the
day is won well it's like with uh it's
like what is what does John McClane new
he you know gets on a walkie-talkie to
you and just you know like he has
stories about his childhood and you know
you share your stories and you know Lucy
is just like beating on both of you the
entire time
kind of thing and then like with with
Dutch I mean I wish that you chosen
predator or like he doesn't have it's
still a human versus a gorilla no matter
what it's it's not gonna play you know
she's gonna take well it's not the
predator you so does that no I know but
thoughts please yeah so um so with that
you're still doing dude
against gorilla I'm bringing a beast to
Abby's fight we're gonna be stabbed is
fight around the horn if so first off
with the dinosaurs you don't watch
enough gorilla videos girls fight beasts
all the time we're taking out cheetahs
we're taking out things way faster than
gorillas here to kill the moment the
fists of a girl it connects with your
spinning which by the way if we are
going on the movie it takes about like a
good 10 20 seconds before it spits the
venom the gorilla would have been
knocked it out now he's stuck in a
gorilla pit trying to peacefully calm it
down
we're talking about 80s Arnold
Schwarzenegger and this is a partnership
there's no way for you to communicate
there's no way you're understanding
Arnold Schwarzenegger in the 8 Arnold
Schwarzenegger who also is a Vietnam vet
he's got stuff going on and he is all
about preparation that whole movie was
him getting prepared the thing with John
McClane he was thrown in a situation he
was there to party maybe get drunk try
and get his wife back and he was thrown
in a terrorist situation and came out on
top that's the type of person I want on
my side as I fight a guerrilla we're
both kind of you know swole tastic and
if we're talking about using guns he's a
cop we all know they shoot before asking
questions so it's over all right thank
you Fe Cameron first of all I'm mark Kia
your point about t-rex was too big
Velociraptor could have brought him into
the party did not do so also the fact
that again Dennis near jury probably the
weakest human character in the entire
film Tim did better than Tennyson injury
and he's a little boy John McClane John
McClane again always needs a partner I
know you're sitting there going like I
can be his partner but you want someone
who can like really go toe-to-toe with
the gorilla not get so beaten up with
their bloody feet and their bald and
head and they're crawling away and then
maybe you get a lucky shot into the
grill you're out pal in this situation
you want to be John McClane that's why
I'm going in with Dutch because at the
end of the day yes you're right it's
like why didn't I pick the predator
Dutch took out the predator give me the
guy who can take out the thing don't
give me the thing and you're talking
about you mainly listen I got a ragin
gorilla after me I love animals but I'm
not against Dutch mud enough and hit
with a log
I do have some facts let's get down to I
have one fact the earth is not flat 17
Arian Foster
the former running back for the Texas
the Houston Texans claimed that he could
take on a wolf this is what he said
partially it this is a long Twitter but
parsing I'm 230 wolves or what 180 200
tops
he has no thumbs if I control his neck
grab his neck he can't bite I've studied
the wolf he can't read I know something
he was very hung up on the fact that
wolves do not have opposable thumb yes I
want this guy to do a werewolf movie
like van Helsing
so got into this argument there was a
deal office source appearance at
Jurassic world but it was a hologram was
not the actual dinosaur from the first
film White Knight is listed at 5 feet 7
inches I went back and looked at the
scene and it's hard to get an accurate
scale but the Dilophosaurus appeared to
be on its hind legs maybe 3/4 his size
it didn't look like a one-to-one ratio
but he definitely gained size on net
jury and was it was a very broad
dinosaur as well so not completely
dwarfed by mr. five-foot-seven
29 or Wayne Knight and John McClane did
defeat Karl in hand-to-hand combat and
dr he just failed to kill him he then
came back at the end where he got shot
in the heart by al Powell so I wouldn't
say he didn't do well in the fight with
Carl he just did not murder him did not
fight Dennis Franz in die hard 2 while
Dennis Franz was very annoying as the
head of airport security yes they did
not have fisticuffs so I don't believe
that a
John McClane should be voted down for
not for me and if I were Dennis Franz
that did not take place he did push me
shoot him with blanks thank you for
breaking it down and I appreciate you
going back and finding the Harry and
Foster tweet oh oh sorry one more yeah
yeah yeah I in defensively night Dennis
nutri Dennis near jury and Dennis Nidre
we're all set in this fight it's Dennis
Nedry first off I love this fight never
forget this third round of Jays movie
fight and it was a lot of crazy a lot of
crazy [ __ ] was said but murky uh man you
said something in your final thoughts
that kind of lost me on it which was I
want to do it in an effective humane way
like it was like like you have that
choice it is gonna be all-out warfare in
there like an effective humane way like
it's gonna be that clinical man I can't
see that happening it's gonna be like
all right if we can get that thing down
and then I don't know it's not that
impressive that your thing killed Newman
from Seinfeld
that's a band like so that's one for cam
Dan when examining the tactics of this
fight I had to look at all aspects and I
agree for me it did come down to iffy
and Cameron if only because while I
respect the choice to the Dilophosaurus
and I love that strategy I feel like
it's to luck based because it's it's a
projectile weapon what if it misses I do
think that they brought up enough of a
thing that the dinosaur while it does
have a strategic advantage does it pose
that much of a physical threat or at
least not as much of one to this large
beast Nedry and the gorillas are very
different
so I'm not convinced that this officer
would handle it as easily as the two
other choices so if it came down to John
McClane and Dutch from predator for me
and I've got to give the edge to the guy
who knows jungle warfare he's taken on a
beast I forgot the camera bottom that
the predator is likely at least as
strong perhaps stronger than your
average girl I could not find any facts
to back to that has struggled with while
he did not struggle with Dennis Franz it
has struggled with some Europeans who
were definitely less strong than a
gorilla I've gotta go I gotta go I've
got to go touch I've got to pray
hammering you just took that point
Danielle what are people saying about
this around just a lot but with 60% the
vote went to Dutch 24% for the dinosaur
whose name I won't even have denounced
and 50% for John McClane a lot of people
I just I can't even call them the the
twitter the hashtag movie fights live is
so good but I think one of my favorites
was from our good friend get shitty who
who posted the real winner of this fight
and then a gif of divorce court this
does I do want to see now because maybe
I'll really examine this if we do have a
net jury versus gorilla fight and I
could get some kind of strength
comparison then maybe I could be more
sway to the Dilophosaurus because I love
that strategy wait you want to see Wayne
Knight fight a gorilla
I need background information on the
uncomfortability loose
well usually it is like you know cuz he
was big big like one all right so that
means Cameron and if he are moving into
the speed round mark eeeh you brought it
and also you were super funny but I'm
sorry but thank you for just
entertaining and dropping some knowledge
on us as well alright so if he is up two
points to one against Cameron speed
round works thusly I'm gonna ask the
question call out your answer the first
one to answer it will be able to
elaborate on their answer first 20
seconds and then 20 seconds then we'll
get 10 second rebuttal 10 second
rebuttal fellas y'all ready for this
yeah let's do it alright question 1 of
the speed round and Danielle will be
chiming in with her own thoughts and
opinions now no more no time for polls
in the speed round
question 1 this week marked the 25th
anniversary of the passing of legendary
comedian actor John Candy so in his
honor what's the best movie featuring
John Candy in any role JFK please
forgive me if I'm wrong about this but I
think I'm right plain check trains and
automobiles yes yeah is there a net film
absolutely John Kennedy and Steve Martin
planes trains and automobiles JFK we
heard Cameron first 20 seconds begins
when you speak John Candy was an
American treasure of comedy but the
thing about JFK is JFK showed that he
could do so much more it showed what a
tragic loss it was comedy as time goes
on goes less and less people will look
back on certain comedies and feel that
they've gone down in stature dramatic
films though often will still stand the
test of time so that means John Candy
was in JFK was allowed to show that he
had a large range and what we truly lost
we didn't just lose a great comedic mind
we lost a fantastic actor and in that
case
while that's true I think you know the
best way to honor someone is them for
their comedy as a comedic actor it's
great to see him nail and acting a
comedic acting role and to not only be
just to himself but next to Steve Martin
it's not only a great John Candy movie
but a great movie on its own and I think
that's something that makes it just
overall one of the best movies I think
both these films are films they're gonna
say that's just the time I think
Planes Trains automobiles people go oh
that's so great I think JFK people watch
it they think it's great but I think
John Candy's a surprise I think that's a
pleasant surprise you see cuz sometimes
you can forget to these in it because
he's not on the poster it's Kevin
Costner movie I believe that's true but
the real supplies come some plain James
and automobiles when Steve Martin blows
up at them and you get that huge
dramatic monologue from John Candy so
you're getting the best of both worlds
in that movie comedy and drama which
makes it perfect whoa all right Danielle
what do you got um once again great
arguments everyone brought it but I have
to it was massive Oh for him to bring it
into last so much of cams argument
depended on being a dramatic role and it
being a surprise
if he was able to show that it's a movie
where you both get to see John Candy at
his best being a comedian and you get to
see that he's can be he can really bring
it when it comes to the acting got to go
with it me this one for iffy Dan I
thought the camera had a fantastic
opening around but if he yeah if he
brought it nailed it and that in the
rebuttal which is that Cameron's
argument was largely about how he was a
great dramatic actor and by bringing
that into and mixing it with the comedy
I think if he got it for me boom if he
takes that point yeah well with you guys
yeah playing trains are our meals one of
the one of the great comedies of all
time all right if he is up 3-1 this is
game points you need this to keep her
going
I mean you take this you take the game
address Elba will replace Will Smith as
Deadshot in Suicide Squad - which other
movie would be better if you swapped out
will for address Ally you're ready for
the spiciest Oh Independence Day okay we
have Ally
we have Independence Day Cameron you
spoke first 20 seconds begins when you
speak now the big thing about Olly was
the fact that it showed that Will Smith
could be a dramatic actor the problem is
though is that seems like there's been
not a lot of good follow up on that
address Elba has shown a great range of
films from stringer Bell to something
like The Dark Tower which is great but
he's great in it also he's actually a
fighter he is boxed on top of being a DJ
on top of being an actor Idris Elba is
extremely likable and Ollie as a person
is just a completely different
interesting complex person
the thought that went into making this
choice is not necessarily what would be
the best swap out because I'm tired of
and giving people I think I think it is
about what will make a new dynamic movie
and it would be interesting to see
Independence Day done by a completely
different dramatic actor who does have
the comedy chops as you can see in his
Netflix DJ movie so that's why I chose
Aegis Elba because to see him not only
be I agree that would be different that
would be interesting but I kind of want
to see interest take on a big role I
feel like he's kind of been lost in a
lot of different movies where he's just
kind of the person next to a bunch of
other people that's what happened with
Independence Day probably gonna happen
with Suicide Squad
this is true but a biopic doesn't seem
like the way to me because it seems like
it just shoves someone in a role and
makes them emulate someone who they're
emulating for the biopic whereas you get
to see him carve out who is his main
character time alright if he I really
like what you said about like being
tired of Aunt fibbing be let's like not
only is that a great line but it's a
great thought but at the end of the day
I got to go with Cameron and Ollie and
just see because I feel Eaters Elba is
like a co-star or a supporting role so
much I'd love to see him at home or be a
the main guy so yeah I'm going with
Cameron Danielle yeah I thought these
were both great points I do I also agree
with the odd Vivek I wished I for me I
didn't get to hear enough from cam I
mean obviously it's great that it that
it just can box we all know that actors
do training for these things it's not
necessary you know look at the do the
plays danielson um and he is likable but
I didn't for me hear enough about why
what he specifically brings the role so
better gonna be alright one one Dan I
think they both made a great pro case
but what won me over was actually
Cameron's argument that it estaba has
been sort of lost in the shuffle a lot
of movies this is a great showcase for
him as opposed to being part of another
ensemble with Independence Day I thought
that was a really good point so I will
for Cameron all right Cameron you're
still in this thing we're still at game
point though so yeah you need this to
tie it up Cameron here we go question
number three of the speed round Angelina
Jolie's Maleficent Maleficent Maleficent
to will hit theaters in October which
Angelina Jolie film should get a sequel
first wanted or salt salt alright if he
you get wanted by default okay alright
so we heard Cameron
first Cameron twenty seconds again when
you talk
Sall was an interesting movie made by an
interesting director Philip Noyce who
has done some of the Jack Ryan movies in
the past I'd love to see a sequel
because that's actually an Angelina
Jolie vehicle wanted though is really
shoved with Angelina Jolie sexiness was
the selling point it really was a James
McAvoy movie her character also died and
wanted so therefore the result to
continue on a spy thriller story
especially now post Russia post all
these other things I think salt is right
to be made and come back into this world
ken makes a very good point which is why
a prequel featuring her character only
would be great because it now gives her
the space to see how dope this character
is I read the wanted comic and her
character is actually pretty dynamic in
the comics so it would be fun to explore
this worlds way better than they did in
the first one now with her at the helm
and challenge those same things they
were trying to do about superhero movies
and superhero world I don't disagree
though I kind of worry a prequel would
actually be kinda disappointing knowing
where things go knowing that she just
dies at the hands of Morgan Freeman's
for James McAvoy at least or the salt
sequel you can see where the world goes
from here what is a female spy in the
world post Trump
the reason it's taken so long is because
it's hard to think of a movie that
rebuts that claim because there is a
movie I just can't remember the name but
knowing that someone dies doesn't negate
the fact that it's a good prequel and
post Trump is so post done we've seen it
so many times I'm oh boy man I I thought
this was a really strong argument from
both yeah I feel like if he edged it out
at the end there I liked Cameron's
opening but I feel like I don't know it
just didn't jump out of me your your
closing argument and I thought if he
made a great point the it's knowing
character dies does not make a prequel
bad people can be entertaining as hell
that way damn I feel like Cameron really
painted it into a corner in his opening
statement and then if he like parkour up
the wall and across the ceiling and out
of the room because that was a great
dodge of a lot of really good points
about it by an opponent and then I
thought the rebuttal against even
Cameron's rebuttal is also good so just
for great counter arguments and still
being able to overcome a lot of
negatives about your choice especially
one that you didn't pick I'm also gonna
go with if he if he you just took the
game
nicely done in that speed round you made
a hell of a ball game awesome job funny
and yeah well played please give some
shoutouts tell us where we came from
yeah I definitely check out my podcast I
have candy dinner with my oldest friend
man apodaca drops on Monday and they're
different on Tuesdays I'm on Twitch all
my twitch has a few of y'all came to my
twitch and said they're excited what's
up nerdy black kid if you're watching
what's up but yeah he's following so but
it's if T's on Twitch IFD EEZ playing
lots of destiny to an apex if you're
into that and lots of memes awesome
Thank You iffy
Cameron great stuff today yeah tell us
some stuff you follow me on Twitter at
Jurassic alien also go check out my
photos cameras photo on Instagram and
also next Tuesday Tuesday night over at
twitch.tv slash irpg I'll be doing he
left it dead 3 joestar's gonna be
jamming that so I'm gonna be a cast
member on his show very cool awesome
stuff thanks brother um Marky uh always
great to have you and yeah um great work
today please tell us tell some things uh
yeah you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at mark and McCarty and if you
have DC Universe I'm on DC daily you can
see that Monday through Friday we have a
lot of really great things coming up
this year because it's you know the 80th
anniversary a Batman so yeah there's
know a lot of a lot of really cool
things also if you watch Collider at all
is on Collider movie talk we talked
about the Hello Kitty movie it was a
very fun conversation two of us wanted
to talk about it one of us was like no
so yeah check out that on Collider and I
have a bunch of different things I'm
gonna be doing like some live events and
some live hosting so please follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and come out to
the events hell yeah thanks Marcia let's
go to the van cam Dan Morrell Dan uh
yeah thoughts what so it's gonna win the
box office this weekend what Captain
Marvel oh yes there you go
we got away box office it's just how
much is the question uh-huh which will
be very interesting watching the time so
what's the hundred million dollar range
you're thinking what do you thinking
well you do their forecasting or
somewhere around one hundred million
dollars I think we have a good idea
tonight when we see what the preview
grosses are but I I don't know I it's
it's the opening weekend is important
but I feel like if it's less than a
hundred million dollars a lot of people
are gonna write it off as a
disappointment or whatever but you know
matrac you spent all over the place so I
don't even know what to expect right on
right thank you Dan
Danielle Radford oh thank you for just
in enlightening us and just being
entertaining and wonderful oh thank you
I also I want to give a big shout-out in
congratulations to cam for getting his
first two points every Halloween edition
meet Clarke and Emma I almost become
really I am what's a good sports team
that's good bad good good bad bad bad
[Laughter]
[Applause]
stole my sports team so I don't have one
anymore
all right easy Idol SuperSonics
SuperSonics I mean you can find me as
per usual Twitter video Radford and just
Instagram and then you know underscore
Radford all those good things
Thank You Danielle please follow
Danielle Radford follow everybody here
and uh yeah why not follow me while
you're at it at Hal Rudnick on Twitter
and Instagram if you want to hear some
stupid stuff about movies and TV I'll
say it um I want to thank Billy Pez I
want to thank jte and everybody here if
he's sorry about the chair
after our nation thank you for watching
see you next week bye
[Music]
you